hello the site of some russian troops
appearing to pull away from the border
with ukraine has been met with some
skepticism as diplomatic efforts to
avoid war continue the russian president
and german chancellor opened the latest
line of dialogue with both saying
conflict can be avoided but as torso
jabari reports from moscow more
conversations are needed before the
chance of war retreats
russia's defense ministry says these are
some of its troops which had been
positioned on the border with ukraine
they are returning to base after
finishing training exercises
as the training comes to an end the
troops as usual will march back to their
home stations units from the southern
and western military districts that
completed their tasks already have
started loading on trains and motor
vehicles they will start moving to their
home bases individual units will march
on their own in military columns
while this raises hopes that tensions
could ease between russia and ukraine
there are still large-scale military
exercises taking place
and it's not clear how many units are
being pulled back
news of the troops drawdown came just as
the german chancellor olof schultz
arrived in russia for talks with
president vladimir putin who said war
was the last thing he wanted
do we want war or not of course we don't
and it's for that reason that we have
submitted a proposal as to a negotiation
process as a result of which there
should be a guarantee for security for
everybody including our country
chancellor olaf schultz said some
aspects of russia's demands on ukraine
were worth considering while stressing
the need for diplomacy to succeed the
diplomatism
today i fully agree that diplomatic
efforts have yet to be exhausted
we have to find a peaceful resolution to
this crisis
several troops have been pulled back
which is a good sign and we hope that
this will continue in the belgian
capital nato secretary general jen
stoltenberg expressed cautious optimism
at the news of the russian drawdown
there are signs from moscow that
diplomacy should continue
this gives
grounds for cautious optimism
but so far
we have not seen any sign of
de-escalation on the ground despite
these intense diplomatic efforts there
are still many outstanding issues at the
heart of the crisis
vladimir putin says he is ready to talk
to u.s leaders about ukraine's request
to join the 30-member nato alliance and
he says that is a conversation which
cannot be put off any longer something
both nato and u.s leaders have refused
to discuss so far
and until that issue is resolved it is
now clear that this crisis could
continue for months to come
dorsal jabari al jazeera moscow
ukraine and western leaders say they
haven't seen enough evidence that
russian troops are withdrawing the
circles are where russia is thought to
have deployed more than 130 000 troops
surrounding ukraine on three sides
russian soldiers also deployed in the
annexed region of crimea and back
thousands of fighters in two rebel-held
eastern provinces
hours before russia's withdrawal
announcement a u.s defense official said
ground units were moving closer to the
ukrainian border a satellite company
said there was increased military
activity in belarus crimea and western
russia including the arrival of
helicopters and fighter jets
the uk says russia is building field
hospitals near ukraine in belarus which
could mean an invasion is being planned
it also says battalion tactical groups
are being taken closer to the border
step vassen is in luninette in southern
belarus one of the places russia has
been building up troops she gave us this
update earlier
i have to say there's quite some
skepticism here also in the south of
belarus about this statement that the
russian troops are leaving or about to
leave it's also very hard to verify this
statement here on the ground because
there has been some footage released by
the russian ministry of defense showing
tanks and troops leaving but there
wasn't any mention of date or time or
location we're here at the london yet
air base which is one of the locations
where reportedly high-end equipment from
russia was brought in as far as 10 000
kilometers away from the far east the
eastern command apparently s 400 missile
defense systems are here and also sukhai
sukhoi fighter jets well we know now
that this exercise or whatever is
happening here hasn't ended because just
uh 20 minutes ago we heard a fighter
jets taken to the air presumably on a
training mission
so definitely activity here still in
lunan yet and it's also interesting to
note that the russian ministry said that
the western and southern command was
going to be withdrawn back to their
bases in russia but they didn't mention
anything about the eastern and central
command and what we've known so far is
that there are many troops brought in
from the far east
the ukrainian government says the
websites of its defence foreign and
culture ministries as well as the two
largest state banks have been taken
offline by a cyber attack
inside ukraine anxiety is building as
residents consider what to do if russia
launches a ground invasion natasha
butler reports from kiev
slava says his son ivan brings him joy
in what he says is a world of hysteria
he doesn't want to leave his home in
kiev but says he'd consider doing so to
protect his family if russia were to
invade ukraine
every day i'm thinking about what to do
with my family or as i go to view for
example to western part of ukraine or go
to village where my
parents of my wife
live they have small house but at least
they have
for example they have electric generator
they have solar panels so at least we'll
have electricity for example the fridge
will be working
most people in the city are tired of
thinking about what russia might do next
for eight years they've lived with
conflict in the east of the country
between ukrainian forces and
russian-backed separatists but the
recent crisis is fueling a renewed sense
of anxiety
things seem very normal in the city
people are still going to work or to
school the shops and restaurants are
busy but as the situation continues some
people that we meet tell us that they
are worried and making contingency plans
if there is an invasion we will go to
western ukraine but if there is a need
to fight my entire family will
russians are just showing off making
noise play acting russians aren't only
influencing ukrainian opinion but
everyone else but russia will destroy
itself if it invades
diplomatic efforts to avert a new war
have seemed at times to go round in
circles with little sign of a
breakthrough moscow now says it's
pulling some troops from the border but
ukraine's government is skeptical
we continuously hear different
statements from the russian federation
so we have a rule we believe not what we
hear but we believe what we see
if we see the pull out we will believe
in the escalation
40 years ago this huge arch was built on
a hill in the city to celebrate russia
and ukraine's friendship since then
someone has painted a large crack in the
monument
no one here wants a new conflict but
history has taught them to be prepared
natasha butler al jazeera
in the next couple of hours u.s
president joe biden is due to speak
about ukraine let's get more from our
white house correspondent kimberly
hellkit and kimberly what are we
expecting to hear from him
well according to the white house press
secretary jensocki the u.s president is
expected to address the american public
in the world from the east room of the
white house at about 20 30 gmt he is
expected to talk about the situation on
the ground in ukraine as well as the
steps that have been taken thus far to
avert war and the actions that the west
is prepared to take should russia invade
ukraine now
in addition to this we expect that the
u.s president will talk about what is at
stake for the united states and the
world if this conflict is not averted
and how americans could potentially face
repercussions here in the united states
something that many americans really
have not thought much about of and this
is certainly going to be a bit of a
wake-up call for some who are watching
or thinking about this for the first
time now in the interim the president
prior to
making the speech has been speaking to
world leaders at least he did speak to
the french president emmanuel macron we
don't have a readout of that call yet
but we do know that his secretary of
state anthony blinken was speaking with
his counterpart his russian counterpart
sergey lavrov the foreign minister and
we now have a readout of that telephone
call
we understand that the united states
once again reiterating that they are
pushing for a diplomatic solution to
resolve these security differences they
emphasize the need for a verifiable
credible and meaningful de-escalation
of what they call russian aggression
that buildup of russian troops along
ukraine's borders further the united
states said that should russia choose
the path of invading ukraine there would
be swift severe and a united
transatlantic response the united states
at this hour believing that there is
still a window to resolve this crisis
peacefully but we expect when we hear
from the president he will say that that
window is soon going to be closing
kimberly hackett thank you very much
indeed